[موسيقى]
مرحبا بكم مشاهدينا ومستمعين في هذه
الحلقه الجديده من ضيف ومسيره ضيفتي
وظيفتكم اليوم تنضم الينا من عمانيه مصممه
ازياء واحليه عراقيه سعيده اليوم باستضافه
هناء صادق مرحبا بك سيد هناء وشكرا لحضورك
معنا
شكرا على الاستضافه
اهلا
بك وشكرا نحن سعيدون باستضافتك واستعدون
كذلك باكتشاف مسيرتك اليوم او بالتعمق على
الاقل في هذه المسيره الطويله مع عالم
الازياء البدايه انت عراقيه الاصل من
مواليد مدينه بغداد تقولين انك
تربيتي في كندا عراقيه متشبثه بتراسها
حدثنا عن هذه العائله عن الوالد عن
الوالده وكذلك عن الجده التي تعتبر مصدر
الهام لك في عالمي الازياء
صحيح
يعني بغداد اللي اعرفها بالخمسينات
غير البغدادي اللي هسه يعني كل العالم
يعرفوه
خمسينات والستينات كانت جميله شجر كثير
ماء دجله يعني
بيت اهلي احنا من عائله متوسطه
التربيه الحديثه حتى بالمدرسه اه كان
معطيني انا بنت وحيده وعندي اخين بس كان
يعطيني منتهى الحريه اني ارسم همم يعني
حتى كنت ارسم على الحيطان
يعني حتى كانت مرات اريد
اسوي لهم فساتين ابدا ما يتكلمون ولا
يعاتبوني
منذ الصغر هذا الاهتمام بالازياء
بعرف يمكن كل البنات هم يحاولون بس بعدين
اني ضل وياي يعني اباكي انا ومميزات
بازياءهم لانه ما كان اللعب مثل هسه باربي
يشتروا لها هدوم شتويه وصيفيه
ههه
كان لديها اهتمام بالموضوع كذلك كيف كانت
هي هوايات تعرف تطرش تعرف
تتخيلها الموضوع
طبعا الحريه ايضا موجوده فاقدر اسوي اللي
اريده بعدين همم كبرت وهي بابا ايضا عندها
هوايه بالجمع
همم
المحبه ويحطهم كان الموضه جاءت
يعني همم
هاي اشياء يمكن هسه عاديه بس احنا
بالبدايه كانت يعني اختراع جديد جاي واصل
للعراق
ما قبل يغير ابدا يعني ما اكنس كثير كبوا
اغراضهم الاصيله العريقه
وخشب عادي اااه اهلي وبيت جدي نفس الشيء
بيت جدي كان قريبين جدا من النهار حطيت
صوره يمكن كثير جميله همم المناظر يعني
همم
دائما كانت معجبه يعني حتى بالسجاد العجمي
اشوف الزهور
والرسمات الجميله تعلم الطفل كثير
جدا جميل تعلمنا كثير اشياء هي كانت
تعلمني يعني حتى لو بس اشوف عشان تلبس
احنا قلت لك من طبقه متوسطه يلبسون
الهاشمي البغدادي اللي هو الراس الشفاف
هذا
وتحت الكمبينسون او الاتق يكون من لون
فوشيا او اصفر او همم تركواز هذا كثير اثر
التربيه
واشوفها لما تدخل عند الناس
الاوروبيات التي رايتهن بعد ذلك
لا النساء ايضا بالوقت القديم من كانوا
يلبسه الفساتين الطويله ايضا جميله يعني
حسب عاداتهم هما طبعا
بالنسبه لك كانت
هذه الصوره الاناقه والشياكه
ايه لانه اول وحده فتحت عيني
يعني عادي لانه تشتغل وتروح وتجيء تلبس
عادي فستان حتى من اجل من يجيب لبست من
يجي بس الهاشمي
التقليد اللباس التقليدي
عفوا هناء بس نحس بحب القطع
من التراث حب الالوان لديك حتى ونحن
نشاهدك الان يعني بكل هذه الحياه الجميل
جدا والالوان ورائك وقطع
القطع الموجوده وراءك في الديكور الى غير
ذلك يعني منذ ذلك الوقت
تاثرت بهذه الالوان سواء في اللباس او حتى
في همم يعني في البيت كما قلتي
ايه طبعا هو احنا عندنا شمس بالشرق
الاوساط وحتى بكل البلدان العربيه الشمس
دائما ساطع يعني اكثر فصول السنه هي شمس
من الالوان
مو بس اني بعدين اني كنت ارسم يعني
بعدين دخلت الاكاديميه مع الرواد رسمت
كانوا يعلمون خطه الالوان
وشلون تطلعين البنفسجي شلون طالعين
البرتقالي الاحمر مع الاصفر يعني
الرسم ايضا والفن هذا همم
يساعدني بالازياء فيبقى الموضوع على الرسم
التشكيلي متى دخلتي الى هذا الميدان هل
كان في ايام الدراسه منذ بدايه يعني
انا كنت في مدرسه اسمها راهبات التقدمه
ببغداد اللي هي مساحه التحرير لحد الان
مدرسه قديمه من الراهبات الفرنسيه
وكانوا يعلمون الفرنسي هي الوحيده كان لها
فرع ثاني بالبصره فكنت اعرف فرنسي يعني مو
مو صعب علي بس من ما طلعت معدل عاليه حتى
طبعا بالعائله يردون مهندس دكتور فرنسي
[موسيقى]
واحد من اساتذتي اخذ مجموعه من الطلاب
وقرر انه يعطيهم دروس خصوصي عند فكنا
نتعلم كل فنون الحياه مبسر رسم الحقيقه
هذول جيل من المعلمين اللي كانوا بدايه
القرن الماضي الى وسط القرن الماضي همم
يعلمونا بالحياه مو بس دراسه ورسم لا همم
فلسفه الحياه فكنت جدا وهو يعتقد كان انه
انا مميزه بالالوان ويقول لي يقول لهم
للطلاب انه طبخه الالوان عند هناء همم
مميزه همم
عملت اول معرض همم شخصيه
55 56 همم وبعدين
لا عفوا 66
66 وبعدين معرض مشتركه مع الطلاب وبعدين
ضليت اكمل رسم الى ان زوجت بالسبعين
وزوجي كان فرنسي
قلت لهم انا لا اعرف اطبع على الطابعه ولا
سكرتيره ولا شيء قالوا لي لا انت بس
ترجمينا ههه
فهنا تعرفت على زوجك كده عام 1970 وسوف
تنتقلين مباشره بعد ذلك الى فرنسا
انا عشت بالفرنسي
في يوم من الايام انك سوف تنتقلين الى
فرنسا اكثر
يعني تعرفين كنا نسافر مع اهلي الى اوروبا
انجلترا انت يعني ببغداد كان الدولار همم
اتلاف همم
عفوا الدينار ثلاثه دولار كنا نترك الجواز
باي سفاره الصبح الظهر همم
فما كان عندنا مشكله يعني ما حد يفكر
بالاجنبي يمكن انا كنت اول وحده تزوجت
فرنسي قبلي اكو مسيحيات متزوجين انجليزي
بس انا حتى اتذكر بالسفاره علكه ال عقد
الزواج مالتنا بالسفاره لمده اسبوع
وانطوني الجواز الفرنسي رقصا الان صعب
صعب الحصول على الجنسيه
وانا اصلا انقهرت قلت له ليش مو انا عندي
جوازي
نعم يعني الامور كانت
اقل تعقيدا في تلك الفتره طيب سوف تنتقلين
عام 1970 الى فرنسا كيف تكتشفين هذا البلد
لانك كما قلتي كنت تس- تسافرين كثيرا الى
اوروبا الى غير ذلك لكن عندما اتيت لتستقر
بفرنسا كيف كانت الامور انفاك
انه حسيت نفسي كاني ما احكي فرنسي
عليهم الى ان تعلمت زوجي علمني
ممنوع طبعا
بس
لا حبيت تعرفين اقول لكم شيء تمنيت انه
ايديه تكون هيك كبيره كبيره كبيره
واحضن كل باريس
اشياء تعلم بعدين الناس كانوا يتقبلون
الغريب يعني احتفظ
بيه ويقدروني
ايضا البس شويه على العربي يعني بسيط يعني
بس عربي تقريبا بالمترو اتذكر يقوموا لي
من مكانهم ويقعدوني
والله يعني هتجيب يعني انا هسه تغير الوضع
حسيته تغير كثير مع
الاسفانه
وكمه بالعالم
الفنون التشكيليه وكذلك بدا لديك اهتمام
بالازياء مثلا
كيف هو الاحساس وانت تبلغين باريس
شوفي الازياء انا اخذتها كدراسه يعني
بالرسم هو اللي قال لي لما كنت يعني شاف
انه الثلج عالي عندي لوحات ارسم الحلي
الحلاق ارسم العقد التطريز على الملابس
قال لي ليش ما ترحيم تدرسين التراث
لا ما اعرف شنو التراث يعني السجاده
التراث الاغنيه تراث كل شيء تراث
انت انت راح تشوفيني طريقه
الاصل همم المهم همم
لاني اقرا بالانجليزي والفرنسي والعربي
ههه يعني ماكو شيء مباشر يحكي عن الازياء
بس مثلا يتكلم عن النسيج عن
الاستاذ احسن شيء لازم تسوين دراسات
بالموقع
فبديت بديت بالعراق اخذ شمال جنوب شرق غرب
اكتب عن ازيائهم ومعانيها كتابه هذا كتاب
الاخير قد كل شيء بمعنى يعني هذا الشيء
المشترك بين الدول العربيه اللون مش عبطني
يكون احمر
الا معاني
الحلي مشتركه يعني يمكن الشكل يختلف لكن
الساين او ال
الاشياء الطوطميه او السحر اللي بيها كلهم
مشتركه يعني من يحطون مثلث معناته مشترك
او الكف او
اييي كلها هاي كتبتها يعني سويت مثل جدول
لكل هاي الاشياء المشتركه بيناتنا الحيه
همم يعني العقرب كل الاشياء هذه هذا الحلو
بالتراث العربي عميق جدا ويرجع جذوره يعني
الحلي مو فقط هي حلي ايه يصنعها يعني يمكن
ماكسيمام 80 سنه القطعه اللي عندي لكن همم
الرسومات اللي عليها والمعاني اللي بها
لما تدورت ترجع لحد السومريين يعني من
ايام 5000 سنه يعني
الرسومات مثل الحيه مثل
ترجع حتى المثلث حتى حتى
الصليب الصليب المعكوف موجود والى معاني
يعني ماكو شيء هم يسووا الان اذا ما الا
جذور
ولهذا
ولهذا تمسكت اكثر اني بهذا التراث يعني
حبيت انه ما يضيع و لازم نفسره لانه
العامل اللي يشتغل او الخياط اللي ما يعرف
هو معاني هو فقط همم يعيد الرسمه بس ما
يعرف معانيها
العولمه دخلت
ودخلت بقوه وساره بيني وبينها حرب يعني
انا
طبعا بالبدايه كنت بس كبحث يعني
مو احد طالب مني بس لاني حارب واحده كنت
حتى الاعلام ما يهتم بالموضوع
فعلا مهنيا في عالم التصميم الازياء
الشغل انه مصممه
زوجه توفي وكنت بحاجه معديه واهلي بحصار
بالعراق بالتسعينات يعني الحصار كان قاسمه
لامريكان 13 سنه فما يقدرون لا يساعدوني
ولا يساعدون نفسهم فاا وعندي ثلاثه اولاد
يدخلوا المدارس وهم بالمدارس الفرنسيه
ويعني
بال 2005 وفاه زوجك سوف تكون عام 2005
صحيح
نعم اه طيب يعني لغايه ال 2005 لم تكون
اشتغلت بعالم تصميم الازياء حتى هذه
الفتره
في التسعينات هو ترك الشغل كان مريض
ما كان في عندكم
في نهايه التسعينات اييه
دخلت انا على الشغل والحقيقه كنت اسوي انا
لانه البس الاشياء هذه
الصوره انت انتقلت الى باريس عام 1970
وبقيتي هنا الى غايه 1981 تقريبا
عفوا زوجي كان مدير شركه ال ام تيوب
وبعدين صارت الكاتيل واشياء ثانيه
كومينيكيشن
الاتصالات
انتقلنا الى ايران ايام الشاه انتقلنا الى
سوريا الى
لبنان الى السعوديه بس ما حبيت
السعوديه ما حبيت لانه حريتي كانت مقيده
شويه
لا هو نرجع نعيش بالفرنسي
دائما عندنا يعني دائما اغراضنا وبيتنا
هناك اييه متى سوف تقررين مغادره فرنسا
بقيت في الاردن
في المدرسه الفرنسيه
حتى قبل قررت انه ادخل تماما الموضوع
شافتني
ناس طلبت اشوفها كانت كل شيء
[موسيقى]
شو رايك
يعني حتى بالخليج
يعني ابو ظبي اه بديت اكون فعلا كشركه
واشتغل همم عاملات عندي بعدين الموضوع
الثاني اللي جذبني هنا هو الفلسطينيات
يعني همم رئيس يسوون حلو جدا يعني
ومتوفر يعني الايدي العامله متوفره
همم احب تطريزهم واحب ايضا الطريقه اللي
اني اساعد المراه يعني طول عمري مع المراه
مع انه طول عمرك كنت مدلله من قبل الرجل
يعني بابا دلني خالي يدللني زوجي يدللني
بس بس النساء يعني اجمالا اجمالا
يعني همم اهم شيء يستقلون ماديا انا شافت
انه كثير يساعده انت انت لديك ثلاثه اولاد
ولد وبنتين
البنتين يعني او البنتين كان لهم اهتمام
كذلك بالعمل الى جانبي والدتهن يعني واحد
اشتغل
الاداره والثانيه همم
لغايه مؤخره عندما عدنا الى فرنسا كان من
المهم بالنسبه لك ان تشتغلي مع بناتك
بالبدايه هم ارادوا يسوون درسه واشياء
ثانيه يعني ارادوا يسوون حياتهم مثل كل
المراهقين
درسوا بالفرنسي اشياء ثانيه ما لها علاقه
بعدين رجعوا عندي يريدون شغل هناك شغل
وحده ايضا زوجه مطلقات رجعت عندي
وبدات علمهم يعني خطوه خطوه شلون الطريقه
القديمه النجار يعلم اولاده والحداد انا
نفسي
علمتهم واصبحوا ممتازين لكن مع الاسف اجت
قبل كورانا يعني كورونا من اجل توقف الشغل
اصبح الموضوع صعب يعني سواء في كل
الميادين حقيقه طيب امم يبدو حتى انك فكرت
في وقت من الاوقات في تصميم ملابس جاهزه
او بخيته بختي من اين جاءت هذه الفكره وما
هي الصعوبات لانني اعرف انك في النهايه
تخليت عن الفكره همم لماذا
لان القطع اني احبها تنتش مو بس خلاص
اكتفيت يعني احب تنتشر لكن غاليه لانه انت
لما تشتريه اربع امتار قماش مو مثل ما
تشترين 100 متر همم من من تجيبين خياطين
كميه يعني مصنع غير انك على ماكينه واحده
قطعه واحده وهذا تطلع القطعه غاليه اما
اذا سوينا شغل بكميه اكبر ينتشر اكتر
ويكون همم
بمتناول الجميع السعر فا
هذا اللي خلاني افكر بالموضوع بس همم
بعدين همم طلبت ايضا من بناتي ساعدوني حتى
اون لاين يعني من بعيد بس
الهم حياتهم مهتمه وشفت نفسي انا مريت
يعني الان ما عندي مشكله اقول تحديت 70
همم
شفت انه راح راح اوجع مطبات واحده
قلت لهم اوكي معناتها انتم تشتغلون ما
تردون روحوا ههه
اه قمت بما فيه الكفايه ولا زالتي ما شاء
الله عليك طيب حدثينا عن عن بصمتك انت
بصمه هناء صادق بعلم التصميم انت ادخلت
الحرف العربي
والكتابه العربيه على همم تصاميمك منذ
اكثر من ربه
حديثنا عن ذلك وعن اهميه همم هذه البصمه
بالذات الحقيقه انا همم طول عمري احب همم
الحرف العربي اللغه العربيه الرائعه الشعر
اقرا الشعر وهو اقرار الروايه تاريخ لكن
الحرف العربي ممكن ترسم همم ارسم الحرف
طريقه تشكيليه
فحبيت ايضا انزل على طبعا تقدراني
بالبدايه قالوا كانه همم وحده لابسه جريده
وماشيه ههه
وبعدين قالوا ليكون قران وحرام حرام
هذه واشعار غزل ايضا
بتشجعين على الفسق يا سلام
كان عندي هدف اني انشر هذه الثقافه
العربيه ولحد الان امم الحقيقه شغلي مو
تقليدي يعني مو تقليدي لا هو فلكلور ولا
هو
تراديشنال يعني تراثي تماما ولا هو حديث
القصات تساعد المراه على الحركه لان
المراه الان تركب سياره تطلع باص طائره
تحتاج شيء مريح لها مو مثل قبل كانت
الازياء مصممه حتى تشتغل مثلا بالحقل او
اذا بالمدينه للتباهي همم يكون شيء زياده
مثلا مثل الهاشمي اللي عندنا ههه
الهاشمي يكون طويل يسحل متر
معناتها طويله حتى تبين المراه مدلله
معززه ما تشتغل بالحقل ولا بالمطبخ
ازياء لها تاريخ ولديها معنى يعني
ماكو شيء بالتراث مالتنا معنا هذه يعني هو
يحكي من اشوف القطعه اني ادرس تاريخ من
عندها ان كان ازياء او حليب العربيين
العربيه العربيه
المهم همم
اشتغل مثل اللوحه والان من زمان يعني بديت
اوقعها لانه انا اتونس عليها يعني ابقى
هيك اتونس همم احطها قدامي ازوقها ازيتها
مره احط لها زرار
الريش
الى الان اشبع منها تماما مثل اللوح
تطلع قطعه واحده
الناس تيجي تقول لا اريد هذا بلون ثاني
والله ما عندي اريدها
يعني كل مره تحضري فيها بعد الاحيان يعني
قطعه كل مره القطعه وحيده وليس منها انواع
اخرى واشكال اخرى والوان اخرى
رائع
لكن انا مكتفيه لانه يعني
روحي بالفن اااه متشبعه
تونس
اربعه اشهر اربعه اشهر حتى لو بعتيها باي
ثمن يعني حرام
والحمد لله
همم المثقفين والمثقفات
الناس اللي عندهم فلوس ايضا بداوا شويه
يفتحون ويردون شيء مميز بس هي ما حد يلبس
مثلها
وصار يطالبون اذا ناسيه اوقعها تقول لي
هاي ما اخذها الا اتوقعين طبعا
فهي تصبح قطعه قطعه فنيه يعني طيب هنا على
فكره وانت تتحدثين عن التشبه بما تقومين
به انت اهتمامك ونرى في يدك مثلا بدراعك
او او قطع الحليه التي عليك همم اعرف انك
كنت تقولين كل ما سافرت الى جانب زوجك
بالعديد من الدول كنت تهتمين دائما بزياره
المتاحف بالزيارات السوق همم اسواق الحلي
مثلا همم وعلى ما يبدو جماعتي اكثر من
خمسه الاف قطعه فضيه عربيه وما لا يقل عن
300 قطعه ملابس كذلك من متنوعه من التراث
العربي همم كانه عمل علمي تقريبا قبل ان
يكون فني هذا الاهتمام باكتشاف القطع لكن
كذلك
بطيخ من وراء هذه القطعه قطعه التراث
برافو عليك انا حبيت تتوثق هذه الاشياء
لانه بدها تروح يعني
القطعه اللي كنت الاقيها قبل 30 سنه من
مستحيل هسه الاقيها انا كنت بمصر الاسبوع
الماضي همم عاده من ارجع من مصر جايبه
وياي على الاقل شيء اثنين ثلاثه كيلو ولا
قطعه واحده يعني خاتم ما قدرت كلها جديده
ومشوها والقديمه اللي موجود اكثر تنك ما
اعرف شلونه صب يعني
مع انه مصري حلو لسه الحرف موجود مثلا
العراق شبههم همم
انا اقول هذه على الاقل احفظها لانه همم
اليهود لما اجوا على اسراء على فلسطين
وهذا موثق من قبل وحده كبيره بالعمر قالت
لي كانوا يجون طبعا الذهب بسهوله ياخذوه
يسيحو حتى اهل البلد يغيرون يعني انا عندي
اساور تطلع موديل جديد غير الموديل لكن
الفضه كونها رخيصه
وبالقرعه تستعمل هذول ما يغيرون يعني
تشوفيها ولا اكل يعني تضل نايمه فيها
تشتغل بيها اااه ما يغيروها فهذه تحفظ
التاريخ يعني احنا احنا جذورنا هنا
على القراءه ويسيحوها
يعني ما تقولينه ان ان هذه القطعه هي جزء
من التراث ومن ذاكره اي شعب
ويجب الاهتمام بها اييي يعني طيب لو عدت
الى قصتك انت طيب هل فكرتي مثلا هل فكرت
مثلا بانشاء متحف لجامع كل هذه القطع التي
انت جمعتيها
والله انا مستعده اعطيهم مجانا
حلو لكن كانت الفكره للعراق بصراحه لانه
همم مع الاسف انتم يمكن من دول عربيه
عديده همم اللي يشوفون البرنامج اسالي اي
واحد يعني اني بالاردن ساكنه اسال همم
المختصين حتى بالمتاحف اقول لا تعرف شيء
عن همم الازياء العراقيه جارتكم السوريه
بيقول لي لا المصري تسالي يقول لك لا طيب
ليش ما تكون لان انا المجموعه اللي عندي
والبحث اللي مسويه على
المقارنات والحل والازياء العربيه اسم
الكتاب بلا حدود
ما كان في حدوده فانا مشيت على هالطريقه
هذه همم انه يجيبوا لنا المدارس
واحده انا ما اقدر احمل بندقيه واحميه
وانت العربيه لكن اجدر بالفن وبهاي مجموعه
اقاوم واقول لهم اني موجوده خليجون
المدارس بالابتدائيه يشوفون تونس الشيء
يلبسون همم مصر شيء لبسون اليمن شيء
يلبسون السعوديه يشتلبس العراق يصير عندهم
همم تقارب فكري اكثر همم هذا الفكره كانت
هالشكل وانا متاكده لما ابدي الكل
الكلاكترز يمكن يسوون نفس الشيء
معارض ولو كانت ليست متحف يعني بل على
الاقل المعارض لان بالفعل هل ما احس هو من
كلامك وكانك تقولين ان الاهتمام بالتراث
اليوم اصبح نوع من المقاومه
برافو عليك
يعني
صار عيب يعني واحده اذاعيه لسه العجايز
مثلا الفلسطينيات من يلبسون
الثوب الفلسطيني نوع من المقاومه بس مع
الاسف احفادهم يخجلون انه شلون هاي التيته
لابسه
سويت معارض هالقد حكيت هالقد اعلام
اسوق للتراث العربي
عن الازياء العربيه
الفضه مثلا في عده دول عربيه واوروبيه
كتبتي مقالات كذلك اصدار
العديد من الكتب منها رمزيه الوشم للمراه
الاردنيه منها زينه المراه العربيه في
الامس والقريب وكذلك الازياء والحليب
العربيه بلا حدود كما قلت ارتفاع بالنسبه
لك توثيق هذه الذاكره مسؤوليه على كتفي كل
واحد وانت على الاقل تهتمين بهذه
المسؤوليه
جدا واتمنى من خلال برنامجكم يعني اني
اناشيد الكل ان يتوقع يعني بعد ما تعبت
اني ياخذوني ورايا الجيل اللي بعديه انا
شايفه انه اذا انطيناهم يا تراث بشكل صحيح
وفسرنا لهم زي ما قلت لك قبل شويه انه
منهم صغار نعلمهم عليه يعني يرحلون
المدارس ياخذوهم على المتاحف اتصور رح
يعيش مره ثانيه انتاج يعني هو الان ااه
مغير او عنده كومه يعني
ههه بس ممكن انت
اكسجين وانا اتمنى من اي دوله ممكن اذا
عندها مجال يعني فرنسا اتصلت بالمزيد لهم
قالوا لي احنا ما عندنا طبعا
بالمتاحف هذه ممكن يحطوه بالمستودع ومن
يحتاج يطلعون عن المعرض العراقي او شيء
لكن مثلا مثل الخليج بده تشتري تراث من كل
مكان ممكن ايضا همم يعني باسوا الاحوال
العراق ما اتصور يعني همم الاردن همم ما
حاولت ادخل ما معنيين كانوا عندهم مشاكل
ثانيه يمكن همم
هذه الفرصه للحديث عن ذلك امنياتك اليوم
هل هي عرض هذه القطعه العراقيه بالذات
القطعه اولادهم اكيد ما يحتاجوها يعني هم
عايشين بالفرنسي تعرفين بيوت فرنسي
[موسيقى]
هذه القطع لازم تنعرض بمتحف وهي مو قصه
متحف يعني تكون بمتناول الجميع ان الكل
يشربها وانا بس يعني يهمني انه الكل يتفرج
العراقي شكو عده سوريا الغنيه بقعدها حتى
لبنان السعوديه همم اليمن اليمن يا حبيبي
ليبيا الجزائر يعني شيء عظيم عظيم ليش
الصغرون حرام
سويت الازياء سويت الحلي انا يعني حتى
ابيع حتى اقدر امول مشاري بس يعني وحدي مو
كافي همم
امنيتي فعلا انه اذا العراق تحسن قبل ما
اموت راح يكون كله للعراق لانه العراق بدل
اول بلد هم جدا
وشفت بلد ثاني تونس انهم يوم يحتفلون بيه
الكل يلبس يعني حتى الاطفال بالمدرسه حتى
موظفين بالبنك يلبس السروال كذا كثير حبيت
الفكره همم بس البقيه لا يعني يراجع دفعه
دفش دفش دفش
شيء مو مهم مو مهم ههه
للتعريف على هذا التراث
الان طيب اين انت اليوم في هذه المسيره
الفنيه
ده اسحب
لا يعني سويت عروض اكثر من 30 دوله
ومحاضرات مثل ما تفضلتي حتى باليونسكو
باريس
بالمواقع النسائيه حتى عند المخيمات بكل
مكان بس همم ايضا ما يكفي يراد الاعلام
والحكومه مثلا ندخل امنيتي يدخلون التراث
كماده تدرس الازياء لانها تاريخ ممكن
الاغنيه ممكن السجاده ممكن حتى الاساس
البيت النحاس كلها بس ماده التراث تدرس من
ابتدائيه لانه الابتدائي هذا ينحفر بالمخ
و ما همم ما يروح يعني يبقى دائما
فهذه امنيتي واتمنى انه مجموعتي همم
اكيد اقدر ابيعها متوفره
همم الان بكل مكان يعني حتى القطعه
اليمنيه اللي عندي صراوي يسوون كوفي
بالمكائن عليها تنك همم واقدر ابيعها بس
حرامات ابيع قطعه قطعه لانها موثقه
وتجمع تراث بلد بلد ومعانيه والاشياء
المشتركه بين الدول بيها يعني الاقمشه
المشتركه بيننا الحرير القطن الكتان اللي
يزرع بالمناطق كلها هذه بعدين المناجم
الفضه والذهب كانت موجوده ايضا عندنا
بالدول العربيه وكلها كاتبتها كاتبه عنها
وشلون كانت الحلي تنتقل يعني في قطعه بمصر
خصوصا ليبيا في قطعه انت تشوفيها بفلسطين
تلبس القردان يسمع باليمن
فكان حتى كاتبه بكتابي صعوبه التعرف على
القطعه بس مو مشكله هي كلها من دول عربيه
يا مكشي مستورد يعني حتى تشوفين بالافلام
الاسود والابيض همم الموديلات يمكن مال
الازياء شويه مستورده بس الفلاحات نفس
الازياء نفس الحليليه
حتى العفش بالبيوت حتى كلها مصنوع محلي
يعني وقصدت العولمه ما قصدت التكنولوجيا
تصدقت هذا الشيء شخص يعني ما احب بس قصدت
مثلا ناكل كلنا نفس الشيء
الى ايام الطفوله عندما دخلت كل هذه
الموضه في الاساس مثلا واصبح الناس
يتخلصون من اساسهم التقليدي هذا ما تقصدين
العولمه التي لا تحبينها يعني
ايه يعني ليش اني اكل نفس الاكل اللي
تاكله امريكا ليش انا البس نفس اللبس اللي
تلبس فرنسي ليش انا البس الحلي لانه
باوروبا يلبسون شيء ناعم سنسال ناعم حتى
بالنسبه بقي يعني مو جديد هسه جديد يخافون
من الحراميه والسراء لكن هم مو بلد خير
احنا بلاد خير بعدين كانت المراه بتحط كل
فلوسها ما فيش بنك بتحطها بالحلمتها
يعني الموضه الاوروبيه والموضه الغربيه
التي اصبحت كذلك تستلم من هذه القطعه
العربيه والقطعه الافريقيه الى غير ذلك
شيء جميل
الحضارات جميل انا ايضا يعني قصات غربيه
اللي هي ما اقصد القصه مالت الهاشمي مالت
بيبيتي لانه مو عملي لكن اخذ قصه اللي هي
تكون عصريه بس ادخل عليها الفن العربي ومو
بضروره يكون كل العراق او مرات يسالوني
هاي القطعه عشان عراقيه ولا ولا مغربيه
ولا لا يعني ممكن يكون لكم يمني ممكن يكون
تطريز خلص
هذا حلو هذا اللي قربنا من بعض انا سافرت
لكل الدول العربيه رائعين يحبوني واحبهم
يعني ما كان عندي مشكله احنا ما نقول فقط
الدين واللغه وانما التراث ايضا يجمعنا
التراث العربي الجغرافيا تقريبا نفسها
اكثر شيء همم سهول قليله الجبال عندنا بكل
الدول العربيه الشمس ساطعه بكل اخيرا ايضا
تقريبا نشابه همم حتى بالتاريخ تشوفين ابن
بطوطه وصل
الدعوه يعني كثير اشياء مشتركه بيناتنا
ليش ما نعيدها ليش ما تكون هي قالت مختص
باعاده هذا الشيء هذا اللي انا متعبني
وانا اتمنى ان تتحقق كل هذه الامنيات
اشكرك جزيلا شكرا انا على هذا الحوار
الضيق وعلى ادخالنا في عالم الالوان
والازياء والتراث في كل هذه المناطق ومن
العراق خصوصا شكرا جزيلا لك
شكرا لكم شكرا على الاستضافه من محطتكم
الكريمه شكرا
لك وشكرا لكم مشاهدينا ومستمعينا من مونت
كارلو الدوليه على متابعتكم لهذه الحلقه
الجديده من ضيفه مسيره ابقى معنا على
اللقاء
[موسيقى]